greetings from podcast Ville it's Monday
the [__] 18th of November the
church is brought to you by manscaped
listen support the Church of what's
happened now manscape is the best
immense below-the-belt grooming this
thanksgiving if you want them to say
gobble gobble
you gotta trim that [__] Bush down
you can't be walking there like [__]
Julius Erving with an afro and have
people want to suck your dick it smells
like onions like that don't let bad
hygiene get in between you and your
[__] give somebody establish carve up
that [__] bush down there with
manscape
they created the only tool you need to
shave your balls it's called a lawn
mower 2.0 and right now the church can
get 20% off your first order when you
use promo code Church CH you are CH at
manscape calm and if you order the
perfect package they'll throw in a free
travel bag when you use promo code
Church that's manscape use promo code
church for 20% off your first
[__] order clean that bud and
salute the flag get manscape the church
is also brought to you by on it calm
listen audit is the best alpha brain out
of this doing this our contest when you
are alpha brain you get a lottery ticket
you're gonna win a little something
they're gonna give you something but
then it gets reinterred into a bigger
contest and you're gonna win the honored
experience to take two grand three days
of training you're going on to hang out
with [__] celebrities down there in
Austin do me a favor go to hot it dark
on it not come right now look at the
great selection of supplements you see
something you like pressed Church on the
way out and get that percent sent right
to your [__] house kick this
[__] meal leaf greetings you bad
[__] it's Monday morning I'm
sorry about last week I thought if you
watch you could tell I can't even get
[__] comfortable light or something
in the leg I'm doing an MRI on Tuesday
or Wednesday to see what the [__] it is
I just took a fall down greeting me
today at the church with me today at the
church is my main [__] Jorge
Perez
soldier what's up my main man the mother
[__] [__] hey drop it on
these [__] I'm a lot of pain so you
gotta work with me today let me get one
of those pillows maybe that'll help me
[__] oh there's another one over
there
oh happy a little better if something
hurt it's pinching the [__] nerve
that's some [__] that's what's going on
it's pinching the nerve iced it
impossible well [__] it we'll do the
podcast Colin Kaepernick you see that
[__] jumping up and down
talk about black people no boy the rent
is due all that [__] back fire
[__] you see him out there
yesterday running jumping yeah [__]
[__] black people he had a shirt night
I'm not never taken to me again I'm
saying what the [__] was it for what did
you get nothing you got yourself in
trouble now nobody there you gotta come
begging like a dog I tell you you gonna
walk out on your feet or crawling on
your knees you follow me they take gave
you a second chance take it and cut this
[__] with the [__] black power
you're not even black you're something
else and your parents are adopted
they're Mildred and Joe from [__]
Nebraska and all of a sudden you want to
be Public Enemy give me a [__] break
all right you're back all that [__] he
talked all that kneeling for what to
come back and you see him yesterday
smiling yeah [__] these black
[__] they deserve to be in shot
and [__] he was talking tons of [__]
right or wrong yeah they eat his [__]
words [__] everybody hung up on him
yesterday Obama he's calling people I
gotta try out [__] you what happened to
the knee
yeah [__] rolling he just tried out
for a night I heard a lot of other
everybody all those teams need a [__]
quarterback and he had an afro - jeez oh
you had an afro Bokashi whereas the Huey
has the rules
we'll wait till waiter give him a
paycheck and they tell them listen knock
it off
the same good times yeah this is the
white League okay knock it off
you tried that [__] already you tried
being Martin Luther King and got you no
way your land your sister's couch in the
basement you and Ricky Williams from
Miami remember you want everybody wants
to be a spokesman yeah just shut your
mouth and draw the [__] football till
they break you back then you quit you
got a pension from the NFL and you start
hearing voices and hopefully if we're
lucky you just shoot yourself and that's
it yeah I'm saying what the [__] is the
big deal for ya nobody wants to how well
they did listen stop being a political
activist go do your [__] job
all right at the end what did you do did
you quit football did you start another
company no now you're back like a
[__] like a chicken without a line of
coke you know once they come back I
don't like you but do you have a line
sure we have to suck my big we'll talk
about I told you I it's the same thing
not there's a stripper like that
she doesn't like that no she got fired
three times she tried to get me fired
yeah for my job she was like she would
get all the black girls against me and
be like George is racist like he only
puts us on stage when there's white
customers cuz and third she was just
weird I used to call her Molly Luther
King cuz enemas Molly dog huh dog she's
everything was racist she got the
bouncer fired but then he started
pimping her out and now they're together
and she's back and he's small he just
drops her off takes the car picks her up
like she hates me or her boyfriend comes
to my comedy shows done Emma she just
taking everything racially ripping this
racially motivated to everybody yeah I
had a conversation with a guy when that
wasn't trying to be an [__] you know
Disney gets lost
twisty plus gets launched they got
enough problems 20 million idiots were
there waiting by the [__] button to
sign up the thing crashes
right people upset I get it you know
nine million people signed up in two
[__] minutes
yeah but then like the [__] first day
the next day
Oh disney plus two is racism [__] at
ease even if they were what is it
because they have a black bird what was
oh yeah the black crow and one of them
dumb that's one of my jokes too you know
I saw ya you better check Walt Disney
was checking from you ash in the futures
checking your job Walt Disney has hated
Jews openly yeah so yeah I don't know
what surprised hate the black crow with
black people is that was it I mean it's
not even that far more reach but like
they knew was gonna happen but like the
thing with Disney is like some of the
stuff is from like 1950 like the jungle
but until 1964 I think like did you
leave eight they stopped playing some
national anthem because the lady not
only sang the national anthem but she
sang a bunch of like black people songs
she had land with that there's a stadium
that plays her music and they stopped
boycotting of music because in 1930 she
was singing like a song that you know
burned all the [__] music oh [__]
horrible like black people were [__]
you know slaves like just it was the
most racist [__] you ever heard why
people don't [__] around but they
stopped playing our music that she liked
god Bless America one of us and the
star-spangled banner so she brought that
lovely stadium star-spangled banner
you're gonna die yeah she sang one of
those saw a couple stadium stop playing
that version of wow the news starts to
bang a bear anything yeah so press
Yankee star-spangled banner' incident
see if it's the Yankees I think it's the
Yankees kappa weather so you go where's
the point four years of college
hey you think if Johnny Cochran was
alive Kapernick would have never got he
would have got him on the team fast I
don't know it can't Smith hold on right
so what did she say
so the from a 1939 recording of god
bless america
yeah but what would a mother songs but
she said you're gonna die you gonna die
it's [__] horrible when they were say
the guy who wrote the star-spangled
banner owned slaves so that's Warner
wolf
Wow um she did sus she sang either her
or there was another one
they sang something now listen now these
are the names in this article yeah do
you have to hear the names of the solder
she's saying right there words you gotta
join the website but what kills me is
that this happened close to [__] oh
yeah tower that's why the [__] were
born Wow it's name of music guy who else
that's all the name they list that's why
the [__] were born damn [__] was
like a messed up word back to mr. Borges
is it the satire I don't know well it's
a bad title yeah but this is what gets
me you know what it's from nineteen
[__] twenty five so really there's an
african-american at home right now who's
on welfare who's having a hard time if
the husband came out of [__] prison
there's some economic something you're
telling me that those people are worried
about what Kate Smith saying in 1922 now
so I think people are just out there
picking scabs when they shouldn't
yeah I mean everything together is done
to us is given us ability to pick scabs
like you know what you just can't all
right so the the show with the bird is
racist to you if the african-american
and I get it I'm sorry change it
what feed is going Twitter and Facebook
and you know call twenty other one of
your friends I think Disney's racist
what are you talking about
and people don't give a [__] if you
don't think people gonna get you call
call a thousand black [__] at
all Disney's racist I'll say [__] you
I'm still gonna keep me on oh yeah I'm
watching something on here that's worth
yeah like at $9.99 yes this is a [__]
you know I haven't seen it heard it's
tremendous Disney two sons and again
they're everything but uh do they have
to because they don't know you're right
they aren't affects they'd be probably
on there everything they owns on there
everything that's why they saw it's why
they took the
anarchy often that I heard that Netflix
has no Star Wars or none of them now
this is going to be very interesting
I've heard you know four people don't
know Disney owns ABC who owns Fox a
couple of like a month ago Disney was
did threatening to take off ABC FX and
Fox in the thousands and just dog we had
a sign petitions Wow
Direct TV [__] it was like if you pay
extra you will yeah baby seems like [__]
that we're gonna calm you on you
[__] I know for a fact that they
fired some people over at Comedy Central
two weekends ago yeah I'm the top brass
at Comedy Central
yeah and there's a group you know this
streaming adds a complete difference
[__] oh yeah the game hey Disney is
like a old-school gangster like what's
that American gangster went when that
fool got the heroin straight from China
Disney has heroin dawg they got that
uncut they got the best [__] there's no
bad movies on the [__] Disney and and
that's when people are saying oh there's
a time to watch
they have decades like I called you just
to make sure you knew about it cuz it's
not it's not for 30 year olds it's
mostly for kids like you now you have I
remember growing up I was talking with
my dad about it we had every VHS for
Disney and took up he's a rich
[__] so I'm Jewish I'm sorry
yeah look at us still from cousins and
[__] no we had we had my dad like Disney
my dad proposed to my mom and Disney was
the whole thing but now it's on every
phone every Roku smoking on it for six
bucks a month I don't got it I I always
let strippers come to my house and like
show off and you don't have this and
they'll just log in their customers
account and [__] like well my house
would you log on a sub you like who the
[__] Clary yang a man whose brain I'm
at all those are the fools that paid
this give the strippers that may hook it
up you know it's crazy so we I read this
thing they online somebody posted just a
friend of ours needs like old cable 149
a month then they put Netflix
10:19 item on Hulu and nine anima Disney
Plus internet for the house something
else something else
two hundred and nine dollars and all
this rearranging we [__] ourselves we
didn't have it good enough with the
cable you know in 1199 you know they
even want to reach out to my wife dear I
might forget Showtime and Cinemax for
four hours a month and my wife is like I
don't want nothing mom there
what clothes will get very close to
cancel the TV yeah I don't have my tea
it's it's been this last five nights I
have a stay home and I write and I go
back to the TV and I'll tape sons a
hanneke at 11:00 and oh I am The
Honeymooners
I want something sitting at a yeah
oscillate o'clock has really become
difficult for rakia there is really
nothing it's not I've got 600 channels
and I sit there you've seen the low on
orders I don't want to watch the stupid
[__] FX I don't want to watch six on the
pound life I don't want to watch another
story about drugs on now yeah you know
it just it's really gotten like I think
that's there's so much [__] to watch
that you like I'm giving up yeah I used
to watch cops all the time now I'm like
I've seen every arrest I've seen that
shoot every race like they've done
everything they've been doing that lab
now live PD yeah it's [__] sucks but
does it suck
I've never watched now it's like it
sucks because they have like they got
good-looking cops and [__] you know I'm
saying are like they got the cops I
didn't gonna do nothing bad I think they
show you putting their head in the car
and saying good evening as watches that
I'll show you the real things like drop
[__] soda you piece of [__] yeah you
look at me when I talk to you you black
bleep what about the thing abut the kid
that robbed the toy by mistaken they
sued the City of Phoenix couple weeks
ago what happened this summer's a black
family came out of a Walmart oh yeah
they drew he died you read on them
because a little girl took a little boy
or something like that and they [__]
kick the skinny kid [__] gonna [__]
the black kid was like I didn't do
nothing I'm just trying to be Drake they
[__] give me the leg so [__] hard
it's crazy bro you know dark it's a a
listen I'm at acompaña kick for [__]
taking of me
cuz there are some injustice is there
doing nah it's happened to me they're
doing justice is to [__] everybody
in a white black Latino look at that
girlier then that money I pay for a
lunch school made [__] Santa ass home
oh that's crazy
there was that Cory come back if you
want to learn [__] you know
Tuesday but if anybody spoke to me on
Wednesday I was a little off Wednesday
and Thursday you know it's to wake up
and go on your computer it's a [__]
school shooting I know from where you
live and you know oh wow see these
things when you sit and watch the news
with your family at night like haha look
at this guy
hey it ran off the cliff in Oklahoma
look at this tornado
look at this earthquake in Japan you
know this is never gonna happen to us
well guess what man we've had two
shootings within the Alpha me in the
last year the Thousand Oaks country bar
and that [__] school the other day
you know this is becoming more real and
real the dick had died yesterday by the
way hope isn't [__] help
oh listen to our minyan [__] him let's
leave out whipping him you know like I
told my wife I'm very concerned with
this this is something that's done I get
on the micro yeah because the schools
have to do something
the schools the two things are gonna
happen either the schools are gonna have
to hire somebody I'm not talking about
some frat dude that got thrown out of
basic hey you wanna like I want yeah you
need Rambo for real yeah for reals don't
need some Israeli dudes paying their
[__] money because I'm tell you
what's gonna happen I'm gonna tell
what's gonna happen somebody's gonna get
shot when one of these parents are gonna
go and they're gonna sue la DSU whatever
till they can't pay the teachers no more
because they've found them they've
warned them we have a man my wife have
gone in there to listen something's got
to be done
you people always asking for [__]
donations about we donated for a guard
out here with a [__] sniper rifle ok
so one of these little [__] shows up
we clean this head right off this
[__] shoulders yeah you know and do
you think they're gonna put metal
detectors in richesse areas now cuz it's
mostly happen in the rich area they have
to they have to come to the reality of
it and here we brought it up at the
meeting Wow
you know what man let's do it at the
airport my daughter gets a scratch on I
just want you la des [__] to
know oh I'm taking the time flying in
all three [__] Jews from Israel from
New York and I'm going deep yeah and I'm
gonna sue you for every [__] dime
your work I'm gonna shut the [__]
school down and one of three or four
these lawsuits happening listen in the
long run just hire the [__] guard
yeah school you can't call the police
detail
wait cops get $40 an hour a day on now
at the beatdown we got him because we
were bringing gun to school so that's
why they put him at our school that
thing is no one's bringing guns to
school so now it's happening do you know
something and you got also put beside a
guidance counselor a counselor okay
somebody to watch schools and monitor at
the school somebody to watch the
students and moderate the social
networking like how big are your
daughter's classes because I hardly have
like 48 like 2018-19 so not that big I'm
not sure yeah yeah doesn't really matter
but this is what needs to be done a
guard needs to be put in there and every
[__] school across the country you
know how it's Jones is crazy is that
[__] set it in ten years we're
gonna have TSA at parks yeah you know
it's getting [__] crazy at that point
where parents are gonna go that's it or
somebody's gonna go that's it I ain't
[__] I ain't doing this no more yeah
I'm not doing this no more you gotta go
to a concert lately I mean yeah you went
to a concert and you were jumping up and
down with Danny and
yeah whatever suicidal tendencies yeah
we went to a suicide I have one minute
of the concert if you go to yourself
some [__] idiot you just pull it down
up Oh homie hours yeah you know now when
you go on as an American you get
comfortable.you starting to have a good
time and something happens like a tire
screeches at a restaurant you look out
the window and you're like [__] if I get
shot I gotta run all the way in that
door now that's why when you walk when I
leave the house now I got everything
planned every exit I walk into a movie
theater I know exactly one sitting I
don't give a [__] way you want me I walk
into a restaurant I know exactly where
I'm sitting I don't be able to [__] what
table you got a busboy and they don't
have a waiter for that area good I walk
it over the [__] thing I'm gonna have
an inch of myself I sit at certain but
yeah bro no I feel like DeNiro and Ronan
never have to [__] prepare for
everything
today's work gotta be able to walk I get
a plan to walk I watch and the people
that you love knock it off with the
phone put the [__] phone and you're
popular when you're out pay attention
it's a different world out there well no
yeah you're a more successful dog like
you don't you don't live where you used
to live where you used to live in Jersey
and I was gonna shoot up the [__]
school they'll shoot you you know you're
in another area now and like my daughter
goes to junior high and like I live on
the border of kind of a ghetto side of
town and she was just like yo dad
they jumped somebody today in PE and I
was just like look if it doesn't involve
you you don't do [__] you don't pull
your phone out record if if someone's
getting beat up bad you got a a man stop
homie not around me but like she was
like what happens if they come up to me
I was just like well you just start
swinging until somebody comes what are
you gonna do sit because now a tall kids
make videos of this [__] and they go
hard of what like they make videos of
them jumping other people like to them
it's like the world I haven't told my
daughter's don't ever let me catch you
making a video of jumpin somebody it's
crazy out there right now well it's the
dumbest thing aside the reason why I
never stole a car you're in it yeah
you're right in the [__] car you got
no excuse well it's a friend's car I
left it over here you're in the car you
know when you make a video you're in
video there's no they taped it so you
know anything we do now we're on video
whether we go to the bathroom when we
walk into the dentist office you know
you used to be more than one the doctor
comes and they check your vitals and
they put your finger the thing to see
with your heart pressure is me walks on
you can pick your nose and scratch your
balls stick your finger in your ass you
can't do it no more cuz there's a camera
somewhere in that room and I catch
myself sometimes I scratching my balls
and sniffing um anybody now some just
perception and just saw me sniffing my
[__] balls getting a whiff of this
fresh monkey nut what's going on George
Perez always the [__] eternal hustler
I'll just you know grind in [__] uh
you know working on that movie and [__]
and just tryin to take the next step
dawg you know more of the podcasts a lot
I learned that from you like a lot more
of the podcast more structure like I do
it every Monday now cuz they expect it
some fans believe in death threats a dog
it's Wednesday what the [__] you're in
their rotation yeah I felt bad about not
put one up last Wednesday interns told
me you went down Friday I can't put them
up because it's a waste of your time
you're not gonna be right now if you
listen to podcasts on a Friday I don't
wanna do business with you jumping on
some people you know if you listen to a
podcast on a Saturday while you're
painting the house or why you [__]
sweeping the garage that's one thing but
if ya into a podcast on a Saturday
afternoon instead of being out there
getting some Sun slinging dick what do I
need you get the [__] job
[__] rust hustling oh hey you want to
hear some crazy [__] though I know
always talk about strippers but I work
with them all the time my old boss the
crazy chick the one that had lupus but
and she had a tumor and she's still
[__] people she's back at my job dogs
they were they hired her again no dog
like she has so many customers and so
many strippers like there was 25 girls
at Monday at my job on a Monday she can
tell them on a date oh she's like super
madam okay so they hire ISM
Matt damn yeah no she's the manager but
she runs it like that like she'll come
out and chill on a customer that she
knows and bleh so who do you want today
like just grabbing them down here here
here like like Magic Johnson in 88 just
dishing them off talk how crazy is this
sex industry
Oh homie it's you know what's crazy she
got so comfortable I get sexy her ass
every day I gotta be like chill like I
have to walk around and Mark dances and
like I'll walk around and show like
being a lick and a little like mood and
she like you you ever have that like
crazy uncle that always be like grabbing
your aunt's ass in front of you and [__]
she be late does to be to the strippers
like I'll walk by she belay
what are you doing [__] is like what's
the longest stripper that works over
there what do you mean wait them they
you know how long have you been there
for I've been there for eight years
anybody been there the holy he is with
any woman she's the assistant manager
now you said there's a another chick
she's crazy dawg and how have they
changed them and do you see a change in
sex workers I mean that's oh you know
these are different these are like if
I'm gonna compare a stripper to a
journeyman of construction like a dog
these strippers get up everyday they
make their breakfast they pack their
outfits what are they gonna wear what
songs are gonna play their lunch they
don't leave work they come with the
lunch take their half-hour lunch boom
they got a schedule all right at 12
o'clock Tom's coming and one o'clock
[__] these Phenix some customers fight
each other that's my girlfriend I told
you and like sometimes the girl will
[__] up that's what I like about the
strip club on Matt is the girl I have
too many customers and she'll be like
damn a honker I need your help and
she'll send like a go get that money go
get this money and two managers I got
right now they're the strongest
structured strippers [__] sex workers
I've ever seen done to this day old men
will still come give money just to say
hi because they can't give lap dances no
more now that their managers and they
fired everybody about me because they
knew me and it was just they they came
back dog you know it was crazy you know
it's funny when you become friends with
your friends are that like like I dated
one and I didn't [__] like it when
you're dating one you just turn yet
yeah like the [__] that you hear but you
know I used to talk to her a lot and it
taught me a lot about men's psychology
she would they know us on it there's
some guys like that's that were
disgusting animals want to go on
anything you stick your thumb up your
ass and get the most we could get from
here for $200
but that's what they need there's some
guys that really go in there just to
talk to somebody just like what was that
movie the main players play his club oh
yeah ice cube ice cube and the she had a
stalker she was really in [__] love
with his mind she was in love with him
but she had a boyfriend she had a whole
relationship she had a whole different
[__] life cult you know it's so weird
how a lot of people don't go in there
because they creepy I wanna finger you
something they actually go in there for
companionship yeah if you believe if a
stripper is gangster she's doing her job
she'll string you along so I got a story
how she's married she's gonna go through
a divorce she's leaving him soon she
needs money to leave him though for an
attorney it would be nice if you could
help her and then when you say no what
about sex you go I'll have dinner with
you but I'm Catholic and Wow I'm
Catholic it would really be against my
law that had sex with you and you've
been the sucker would say you're right
you're a decent girl you only take your
clothes off and start dick in the VIP
room
because you have a four-year-old they
really become something listen like it's
it when I kidnapped cats Bella the guy I
kidnapped Kent with his name was Steven
Tidwell he was just a strip club [__]
he was a [__] like I talked to him
every day at the body shop
and every day talking about all last
night you know how lies honey I dropped
300 but poking my partners cuz he had
called everybody his partner nothing
bothers me more than the guy drove will
[__] Ford Fiestas with a busted
window my partner you know I got these
partners that uh did help you out he
would always tell me about Mikey no way
he would go and stuff but if anybody
knows this the reason why my partner
helped me kidnap Bella was because he
was in love I mean dogs this chick was
fifteen ninety three twenty four ripe
Spanish brown little toes that you would
stuck on for hours you know those low in
the grid coast don't want but they cross
without sound my god they were brown but
perfect she was like from Nicaragua then
they're they're hot she was a hot dog
and she had pretty hair and then she was
just a knockout but I had better a few
times because I used to buy weed from it
and she would be over there so I assumed
he was [__] her
and then one night he's like a long haul
she's uh my friends she's a Catholic
girl I'm like she dad like I didn't say
this tool because I know you was
rhetoric it's hard she was at a place
where you bring BYOB will they show you
the inside of their [__] I went in
there one man went crazy before our
Korean girl when I was in the halfway
house like two weeks before I got
married I had my own bachelorette party
by myself
I took an 8 bar and I went to some one
of those strip clubs where she used to
work I didn't know she worked there that
huh the [__] in there were bangin is
he bring your own beer
BYO booze okay you know I took this
Korean chick with fate if I just talk
this is what I got you ain't believe it
and there was like a personal table when
I just emptied that pack
bouncer come and she kept saying no no
no no finally I have a snort coke I'm
eating her ass I mean that [__]
I still remember getting in the car and
jerking off on the drive down to 70
like just jerking off this you let me
[__] everything else to always eat the
[__] ha hatch her [__] I mean it was
a [__] hot and they had a walk into
the halfway house that's what my curfew
was midnight Dan I was loved before so
my hobby was midnight euchre feels like
9 10 11 had midnight curfew a plus cuz
you had a job problem that I had a great
job but it was funny how he met her
there and her claim to fame was that she
was leaving her husband she needed money
for an attorney and that once she filed
the divorce she would hook up with Steve
let me tell how much of a [__] he was
he slept on the couch and she gave her
the bedroom and his own house on his own
until her divorce went through and then
they were let me get together Wow have
you ever fallen in love with the
stripper I fell in love with a stripper
that I met at a comedy club and I'm
saying then you know we fell in love
this got couple but as far as the
stripper I think we've all waited for
that one chick at Denny's
man she told me she was coming I'm
telling you she liked me she likes me
she's okay that sounds like suspiciously
like my boy yeah it would be the only
moment I would say that he would wait at
Danielle he's still sick more so here's
my thing I went once and the girls were
just so hot that like I literally got a
headache just cuz you couldn't you can't
do [__] you can't jerk off I got I got
that's the thing why did you ask like
that you'd be like no I didn't I didn't
ask that's the problem but I'm also too
cheap when they wanted like a hundred
bucks for fifteen minutes I'm like
that's I don't know man well you know
Lee listen well the chick says she wants
a hundred bucks with ten minutes you put
three in the hand and go about thirty
minutes let me suck your puss that's it
what's the point of sucking someone's
[__] that's it to pay for it that's it
isn't fine what are you doing now
nothing when you were taking the [__]
miserable it down the [__]
the the sushi with the [__] belt you
$180 you will get nothing so what's the
difference
leave for a hundred bucks yeah probably
gonna get [__] or jacked off and
you've never been with the girl at this
alright I don't mean to have sex with a
man let him take a yeah it's a nice
little Mexican shake the knees sustained
the contrived you will [__] so much
you'll supply in from the club to the
car I'm telling you live there you're
gonna have to pay some way just go
you're gonna have to pay me now or pay
me later
no chicks don't let you take him up a
hot dog and take you home
now you had died you ask a chick she
abandon ship
you never want to bring it the house you
know you just gotta lift a rock
somewhere nobody's gonna give you that
if another look at your dick look at you
would you suck your dick for free
no they gotta get something I want a
good person I'll join the church there's
a lot of good people it's not God we're
gonna like to get the head spin on women
light blowing you come when they say to
you don't come in my [__] and you come
in their [__] women like when you say
when they say they don't come in my
mouth and you bawl that load their
mouths gonna happen on that fence I
don't let I don't get it that's why
you're a celibate dude you're gonna be
so my man in Selman lawn chair you're
gonna have to sell to get a bit just go
to one of those chicks at the fourth
wall and say look if you come down here
you got nothing going on I got a nice
bed I got food I got the key no dying I
got a juicer we give you a nickel
another jerk off to you maybe yeah don't
spend 500 on a [__]
I'm never gonna have a blows teller yeah
you won a three that's why I said to you
the girl said she won 115 yes you're
gonna give us three four thirty which
you're like Joey should be three four
forty five know that a little that
yardstick is for meanness each of [__]
and come on your teddies when I whack
off right the boots
and if you can't live with that that's
how you negotiate dog yeah you tell them
that right from the start
there's no 15 the dance what I even
going back there less I see that monkey
while I didn't do them get me somebody
who will because there's so many of this
filthy [__] yeah leo suck your dick and
licky ask the cops run in there waiting
it no you go what's in the cotton
thieves you can arrest yeah that's right
going to the club alright or a notice
the girl that keeps walking around and
asking people for dances and they keep
telling no no no no no that's the one
okay then you go hey come here she's
gonna be shocked cuz all the girls seen
her oh [__] she finally got somebody cuz
all the girls they [__] make fun of
each other all this [__] can't get
dances huh I'm gonna tell her hey it's
15 minutes for a hundred bucks right
okay cuz last time like she let me put a
condom on and like I got something and
then the girl would be right there look
you put that column on you're not gonna
be back there for 15 minutes they're
gonna make you not like in seven eight
minutes that's fine
okay that's right now though my just a
minute no hey what are you gonna do my
podcast whatever you want okay after the
podcast we're going straight to the club
okay me inside together bye I gotta say
cuz I've seen clips from your podcast I
don't want to get whipped [__] no
you're not gonna give everything I don't
give a [__] do it on a Thursday so you
don't have to be back til Sunday okay
that's your best bet keep them down
there but I got Jake some chick
physically abused and smacked American
history extra for the mask on with a
ball in his mouth the whole [__]
thing telling miss tsukino diet yeah I'm
I can't mine into it and you ever been
whipped dog no I got whipped it it
[__] me up it's okay
but that's our [__] that's what it's
okay for me to get with them because you
need all the action you're planning your
life anything you could get you could
get because from the fourth wall from
the [__] start they is inferno to
your house is all you see and then you
sit there at ten o'clock and let the
four walls close on it at this point in
my life anything that good night if you
fall down the stairs it's good because
at least something happened I don't know
I agree with that but you don't say how
to protect yourself you need I got
weapon and it kind of lifted a lot I'm
to get whipped spit on so yeah to call
you a filthy Jew that she hates Jews and
she's got your dicks why would you come
and spits in your face you need that
type of [__] you need so you need to
[__] a Jew hater John copy and just to
work those hips until your [__] back
breaks spit in your face telling you
your mother's a [__] that type of [__]
if you need a copy and choke it Lee
they're out there that's just [__] I
wanna live in a world that's crazy how
you say goodbye to your mother but I
kill you you're like stop it I have a
podcast at pong I have a new sponsor Lee
would if I was to arrange that would you
do it he has no choice we go without
this they're getting beat up party no I
mean not beat it's gonna be a beat up
you lying yeah you know like a punch in
the stomach or your punk-ass [__] whip
units on your face you know it smells
good weed from your mouth why are you
sucking [__] a little bit then the
blood mixes with that [__] juice yeah
and you got like a line HIV effect but
it's gonna be alright you Listerine
after we go home you don't breathe on
nobody okay at the beginning but then
you like the slight edge a build up you
need to go to that one massage place on
Lancashire
they got an ugly Chinese chick that
works over there but she'll suck your
dick with cellophane on
I'm telling you I got friends that go
over there they put cellophane on your
dick what the [__] is Sophie plastic
wrap let you put are a microwave they
put a scotch tape like nuts gots tape a
rubber band
no is they can get condoms over there my
friend goes over these are filthy animal
they can't work on those sixties like I
go over there all the time they're great
ones they [__] that's another reason why
I don't want to do it because I imagine
the guys that are [__] these girls
come on everyone they're worse than the
girl in girls I think you know enough or
none you know Craig Robinson good
dollies and clean because you haven't
[__] nobody oh yeah
you gotta [__] some dirty people they
got like the hip build up your
resistance Hey oh my god took my wife
out to eat the ma was a gay waiter and
he brought over the dish and I know is
his tour there's a woman goes it's too
it's too orders I go the plate look like
it's got to have dog he went bail oh
yeah ever heard that expression like an
looks like it's got the hair cuz the
plate looked like they should have been
more [__] clams on the plates got the
hippies oh he's probably still in rehab
over there yeah that's [__] funny
yeah I would love to know I just I'm
always been it I've always been a couple
of weeks who I was talking to this girl
on Facebook she said she leaving there
and I can't say it to somebody you know
this girl was 36
good-looking girl no beauty queen or
good-looking girl she's living in her
car
you know she's living in her car she
doesn't have a job she's [__]
struggling for every dollar you know she
was telling me the positions that she
puts herself in for work and what people
try to do wrong you know
I got my card on the way home you know I
thought about when I was 20
when I was 21 I lived in Aspen in
Snowmass Village and I was watching all
these younger guys oh you know hold the
guys and I'd see these young girls
unless you're a [__] idiot that's not
that girls that's not that guys go yeah
you know and I would look at them there
was this bar at the time called not to
Paragon it was called patty Bugattis all
the time I would see you know after a
while I started seeing the same girls
with different older guys it's it's the
game and I asked the bartender once it
was a sheep I said I was 28 I was I
wasn't naive I didn't know that game
hooky game and how it worked my friends
had taken me over to the 10/40 club but
that's a disgusting place that's where
you go and buy a ticket and then you
[__] chick in the back what the [__]
Oh New York City yeah 10:40 Club and
dolls and forty cents $9.99 plus tax
1040 no way you just put your dick in a
hole and there's a chick on the other
side of you stick to like a ticket you
go in you can order a drink and just
wait them to the chick that you want
there's a hundred guys with Colonna ah
these are all the guys that tell you
probably won that club in Orange County
has tons of [__] that meanwhile they'd
rather [__] then getting [__] their
pain but I went there one time there was
just an uncomfortable experience
together I felt dirty
yeah but she was also a scoundrel I mean
when the chick the golfer dressed and
with all the ugliest thing as I was on
my life it was like she had stockings on
when she took the stockings off I saw
the rashes and anyways she hide a lot
doc they had a lot with those stockings
yeah and I just remembered it was it for
me but I remember talking it to that
girl one night and the one do you you
know are you friends or their numbers in
case somebody comes in here asking don't
get me wrong and I was 18 19 maybe 20
I was 20 [__] she was telling you that
these girls were getting anywhere from
500 to 1,000 a date at the time and
that's if they didn't spend the weekend
like a lot of guys in Texas won't come
up and go [__] it just stay up Wednesday
through Sunday that's a $20,000 week if
you got it you got it I thought yeah I
ghetto and I remember sitting there and
going you know I was raised a certain
way I like girls to be a certain way I
didn't have a daughter then but you know
if I was 21 and I had a tremendous body
and a beautiful face and I came out here
and I ran into these [__] animals
that's just lie to you at the end they
just want to [__] it I would flip it I
would really flip it I would get a good
dear friend of mine I'm telling the
truth
oh I'm gonna cut you in and I want you
to drive I mean I wouldn't put my price
and what's that gonna puss it's 24 do it
I get checked up every week and that's
what she was telling me she goes these
girls aren't dirty they go to the doctor
every week yeah I think if they're
[__] check they get penicillin shots
this ain't they do the King
professionals you know when you're
dealing the [__] yeah yeah like it's a
hit squad you're a mama you can't go eat
at White Castle take good care of
yourself it's the same [__] thing you
know so I didn't know that about how
much maintenance went into being a
professional call girl you know but
looking back at it like at that time
when I was 20
I'm like if I was a young woman and I
didn't go to college and I had nothing
else going on I would make the shortlist
I would go my goals are from December
1st to March 15 up in Aspen
my goal was to pull down a hundred
thousand straight up and there's there's
so many like what you this is what you
do your goal is on a thousand the season
till I'm 25 when I quit I move somewhere
I redo my [__] [__] I get vaginal
rejuvenation you get the memories away
back in and nobody knows what it hello I
got a house I got a call I got credit a
lot to deal with all this stuff now a
lot of women can't do that now a lot of
men can
do that but I couldn't you just [__]
somebody but I'm just saying you know
think about it I could Howard [__]
chicks for 10 grand a week you're not
good off if I was right now he would
give a [__] woman that 70 that's got
tons of money whoa okay look if you're
70 you just can't like yeah I'll do it
dog but like she has to be like she
can't be like on a breather and [__]
like she has to be able to walk like
functioning you can't just like bring a
chick in a doll my aunt wanted to bone a
chola before she died like man I'm not
boiling girls on hospice like they you
know I mean like if you can walk your
standards I will [__] off Nancy Pelosi
you [__] oh [__] I get some dick too
although most of us find out the hard
way that getting into debt is easy I'm
getting out of debt is hard especially
if your credit score isn't great that's
why I'm talking to you about upstart
they offer you smarter interest rates to
help you pay off your credit card debt
upstart goes beyond the traditional
credit score your upstart interest rate
is based on your education and your job
history
not your credit score repeat not your
credit score
they actually reward you for going to
school upstart doesn't care about the
bills you didn't pay five years ago they
care about the person you are now
today and they give you a race based on
that plus they make it fast simple easy
to check in your rate in just a few
minutes without affecting your credit
score the best part is once the loan is
approved most people get their funds the
very next business day the next day over
three hundred thousand people have used
I'm starting to pay off credit cards
free yourself from the burden of high
interest credit card debt by
consolidating everything into one
monthly payment with up start this makes
sense guys you guys are just spinning
your wheels you got all this debt
consolidator giving yourself a goal and
you're out of debt in three four years
took me six years so don't feel too bad
see why I'm starting is ranked number
one in that category with a little over
three hundred businesses on Trustpilot
Harry the upstart
coms last Church and find out how low
your up start great is checking your
rate only takes a few minutes and it
will not affect your credit score that's
upstart dot-com slash church again
upstart dot-com slash Church help
yourself get out of debt anyway back to
you and debt yeah if I was a hot chick
and I didn't have a college education my
options were being a [__] waitress
and getting sexually harassed by my boss
anyway you know how many guys have you
[__] little worthless in all those
years you know I mean really the
dishwasher the Busboys he's cheating on
you you might as well get me you [__]
worth I got a daughter for me to be
saying something like this is very
difficult because you're not but I see a
lot of women that are just spinning your
[__] wheels and listen I know there's
guys I would [__] me either I wouldn't
[__] me for $10,000 I would suck my dick
I smell my dick I know this smells like
it's horrible but there's young guys out
there that I shine that'll give you 300
once I'm left to come over Lee woods
hell yeah if we found the chick that was
cute that totally I'm coming over on the
first you give me $300 you gonna [__] me
that's thirty six hundred a year that
you're just putting away in the bank
anyway you're not gonna do this you're
not doing anything with your money
anyway you're playing for a family plan
you might forget to check the comment
and [__] suck your horn
but 360 that's getting away cheap the
school you came from you know and that's
the truth you ask the [__] Lee once a
month for $300 that 300 that makes her
car payment as a comic yeah you know I'm
saying and leaves a sweetheart of a guy
leaves like yeah he won't spit on her do
not Lee's not gonna do that for you
later afterwards huh
oh yeah God will spread yeah but I don't
I don't I never understood like I should
look like putting it like it let's say
you were a girl and all that stuff
happened like your mom passed away you
didn't have places to live do you think
you would have reverted to something
like that if I was [__] hot
and I knew exactly how to do it and yeah
I knew how to get myself I know the
clientele I'm going for yeah it's all
kind to our clientele they all clientele
them where you put yourself you know if
you go to a [__] kids bar you're
gonna pick up dirty kids you go to a
dull bar and you act like an adult and
you can stay I don't go right now that
charges ten thousand a night and
highlights Wow I'll show you her picture
I can't tell you and that yeah [__]
die
yeah she's worked every fun honey 10 G's
and I only came through to me I saw her
online and she came to a comedy show I
saw her her shoes had to be eight
hundred a person yeah in on gel a half
it was eight hundred and the guy she was
standing with was a moogly a he was a
[__] Mook yeah and after talking to
him Facebook's but like a year and she
finally asked me one day she goes do you
know anybody would be interested um I
don't know if you know this she's got
that actress I want on IMDB the chick
don't even have a [__] picture you
know you think people don't think they
know you know yeah and I guarantee she's
banging some old guy pays her rent she
lives down her sons that boss still does
this [__] she told me when she was
twelve years old that her and her cousin
used to [__]
she took her mattress from the backyard
and they put it in an abandoned house
and they would just sound like the boys
850 bucks
[__] that's some crazy [__] like she
loved it cuz she loved she did it for
the drugs you know and this woman that
do it because of problems at home yeah
fathers mothers [__] like that but
there's women who do it as a business
man straight up
it's a [__] business and they have an
endgame they have an agenda they take
care of themselves they're [__] cool
they don't do drugs that's some dog you
know they don't do drugs and something
like when you go to give a fly-in to
[__] LAX on Sunday from Vegas look at
the chicks you're flying with on Sundays
in Vegas when you go into LAX on John
Wayne Airport
you're flying with the cream of the crop
the Lawrence County yeah you're flying
it with blondes don't make your head
spin
yeah
I'm probably going to Pepperdine they're
probably going to USC true they're like
when I [__] get no job at prop ah
yeah they go to Vegas to go to that
Rhino whatever the [__] I'm Thursday
Friday Saturday then walk out of there
you know I'm dear friends with onyx muse
I talked with your dad I retweet her
stuff all the time she tells me what she
makes
it's yeah she's nothing around and she's
not [__] nobody she's stripping and
she's candid yeah it's different levels
it's all a little bit I tweeted an
article you never like a girl making
15,000 candy a month that's it just by
Cameron you know two hours a night
it's either louder you can drive a new
burger right you know I'd rather show my
[__] for two hours without my face she
has different did you in your apartment
yeah yeah I saw that very interesting
valiant and last you got a TV deal Sam
she does she wrote like a play and [__]
you know she showed a [__] she financed
what she wanted I ain't mad at her no
I'm not mad she didn't sleep in nobody
she got cancer
Howard camps hmm that's that's that's do
or would door yeah took control wise
[__] Cassie said you know what I'm not
gonna host any of these [__] comedy
clubs for the small 200 I want to go
show my [__] build up my thing and
that's exactly what you did you show the
numbers where she went to and where she
took it from you know that's the freedom
we have today and all artists and all
levels that you don't have to wait for a
studio you don't have to wait for
nothing your studio is right there it's
called the [__] Internet
yeah you know that's a good [__] and
like I've watched documentaries I think
they I think they're the only difference
in some what you're saying is some of
them do it for like 12 hours a day like
they have like sets and they they have
games that they play and yeah [__]
kidding no [__] it it's it's the same
thing as twitch but it's just for snaps
I've never been on the under this [__]
like I've been blessed
I'm the guy that works there they give
me money to play music for them like
I've always been the guy that like
they're like I see all the guys that are
getting played and they come in said hey
George host comedy La Roche they're
bringing the chick flowers ha ha you're
buying me lunch today pretty much and
then this like when that guy leaves the
strippers are like oh my god this is so
bad yeah now there's this one guy that
we got he's been coming there for like
six years dawg
he gets a new chick every month he
doesn't care he rotates them and like he
convinced three of the girls to live
with him
what yeah because some of these chicks
fly in from Cleveland anywhere the East
Coast cuz there's more money out here
and then they're like rents expensive
and then this fools like you could stay
up a house free rent and they're like
yeah and it's like he's just waiting and
he doesn't harass him he's just waiting
for anybody
can I stay another month wanna move you
want to move up to the master bedroom
then and this crazy Hughes like any work
to the strip club forever yeah honey
problem I used to go down there with
Joan visit him it was crazy it was in
Santa Ana right
I don't know right by the airport oh he
was that mr. J's right by the airport
they shot movies there you know how many
times I've seen a movie and I'm done
that's what Eddie used to I've heard
that I but I heard 80 Bravo was there
for a long long time it's so funny how
you're there now and it's like your
little sense of humor like whenever I
call you there I could tell you having a
good time hold on real quick all right
guys it's coming up next for you right
here number eight so what's up [__]
tremendous you you're working a lot man
I'm proud of you
thank you brother together I think this
Thursday you're in San Jose yeah this
Thursday I'm at the sound Z and Pro [__]
yeah you know try a brother it's thank
you dog everything you said is coming
that full circle you know I stop whoring
myself foul all the time going back to
clubs once a year more on the podcast
more on the writing thanks my boy it's a
system brother and it's just it's not
quick it's repetitive yes how repetitive
visit your example
doing this again you're gonna keep him
guess what once you get to that level
you're gonna still keep doing it again
oh yeah it doesn't then the grind don't
[__] then the grind ends in people's
minds that's what the problem is people
get to where they're going then they go
what do I do now now is what I needed
your grind
yeah that's not it's not getting there
is knowing once you do once you [__]
get that okay it's a [__] nightmare
but I see what you're doing then I see
that you putting it together but like I
said to you guys I'm really sorry about
last week Maya I just slipped at the
store and now I don't know if I have a
tear in my hamstring I mean it's all
black and blue so everything is up in
the air right now
but Miami's still good to go you know if
I got to pick a [__] even if I gotta
take a school it down there and December
6th at the [__] Town Hall 10:30
there's still plenty of tickets
available for you guys everything else
is sold out [__] Boston Miami's but
New York New York December 6th Town Hall
there's still some tickets up for the
Early Show but the 9 allows I wouldn't
pay that little ass to say me tell me go
[__] themselves
a real lot a dime over 35 yeah they'd
have those scalpers and [__] that buy
don't do that [__] I'll be back there
plenty next year you come don't ever
spend over there yeah
[__] people [__] thieves [__] like
that they drive me [__] bananas
anyway real quick here let me talk to
you about upstart you're thinking that
you're in debt and it's the end of the
world no it's not because getting into
debt is easy getting out is the hard
thing
upstart doesn't care about the bills you
didn't pay five years ago they care
about the person who you are today and
they'll give you a rate based on that
alone so do me a favor
go to upstart back home slash Church and
find that how low you're upstate rate
really is upstart rate really is the
church is also brought to you by man
skate listen this is it the time of the
year your balls your dick area they
gotta be [__] tip-top Magoo is shiny
the last video I put up on Instagram I
showed you I trimmed my nutsack you saw
all those little pubic hairs
my dick is lookin smooth but I'm not
gonna lie to it looks like Sinbad the
sailor they could use another
I'll be trimming that [__] but
Thanksgiving because manscaped created
the only tool you need to shave your
balls it's called a lawn mower 2.0 for a
reason they prove a way to one point oh
[__] that [__] and the up-train is that
trimmer with skin-safe technology for
you mow mows in the back that means it
will Nick or snag your nutsack that's
beautiful
plus it's perfect for travel it's easy
to charge and you can demand scape
wherever the [__] you go let's say you
pick up some freak at the [__] club
you go home you go to pee you take a
whiff via nutsack it smells weird if you
go in the [__] safety travel case
they even give you a son to have these
individual packages a because it might
get nuts for the next little package you
could put them in your wallet that's bad
I forget what they call you just give
yourself a little a little ball wash and
they put that in there the Reviver the
revival they put and flavored ball into
the muck it's like going a little crispy
vent on the way I'm saying forget about
it that's what I'm talking about man's
gate goes the full [__] distance now
if this is your first time manscaping
they got a deal for you it's called the
perfect package it comes in two lawn
mower and the safety razor plus you got
the crop preserver especially formulated
deodorant so your balls don't stink like
a billy goat and they trust me there's
no worse than the [__] Mayflower
without the cats and the Reviver a
spritz that tones and refreshes your
nutsack and you dick pole and it keeps
it nice and cool and fresh and with the
perfect package your pouch will be
padded and your pole will be [__]
perfect now what are you waiting for the
church family gets 20% off when you use
promo code shirt si-hu rch at manscape
calm
slash Church and if you order the
perfect package dog they'll throw in the
free travel bag I got one of those
tremendous by hiding weeds and other
paraphernalia along with your little man
scape your little manscaped two points
although more so that's landscape
manscape calm use promo code church and
get 20% off your first order
clean that [__] [__] wash that
Pole shave it and salute the flag
[__] it's Monday get manscaped
I want to thank manscape I want thank
upstate upstart and I also want to thank
on it for always being our sponsors and
having our back I also want to thank my
man George Perez and the [__]
but I want to thank you [__]
for always having me again I'm sorry
about last week I was injured
but this week we'll make it up here we
got some great podcasts coming your way
I'll see you December 6th at Town Hall
New York City kick this [__] melee